all right so today we are going to make
a turkey and with turkeys uh I don't
usually get to practice that much just
because knowing I never make a Turkey's
from the holiday season so I've never
made a turkey ever in my entire life so
I'm so excited to learn I'm learning
with you today do so every year I had to
do a different variation of the turkey
and this year I'm going to do an Asian
inspired turkey yes and I can smell it
very Asian already yeah he loved ginger
and I did I did
so yesterday in order to prep for the
turkey I pre brine the turkey and
basically what I did was I cut open
garlic and cut up some ginger and I cut
out some bay leaves and I cooked it in
some chicken stock so that made like
this this brine for us to kind of just
soak the turkey if it's just because
when you cook a turkey there's a dark
meat and there's a white meat and the
white meat is gonna dry out way faster
than the turkey because dark man has all
the fat of white meat pretty lean the
Senate dries out so fast we're going to
be brined it so that we would retain a
lot of juice and one boy stur in the
white meat while we brine the turkey we
might as well flavor it at the same time
and so I added a crapola sugar and crab
love salt and I brought it to a boil and
then we let it cool down and then once
it settles down you put the turkey in a
jumbo bag Oh kind of like this one
better jumbo bag like this you fit the
little turkey in there yeah well
technically you're supposed to use a
brine bag they had bags for that but I
can't find any so I use the next biggest
thing I could find that store and so
I've dumped the turkey in there and then
put all the brine inside the bag and now
the brine is gonna be very very salty
because you put roughly about a cup of
salt in it so from here you want to
dilute that that brine with some water
and you can just use cold water and
actually I specifically because I
couldn't submerge the entire turkey in
that bag
I specifically flip the turkey upside
down so the breast it's facing downwards
that I can
Aksum myself at least all the primes for
going to the breast and I could care
less about the thoughts a thousand juicy
no matter what regardless when you Brian
how long should you brine it for
essentially overnight you want to brine
overnight and then the morning take it
out and also you want to Kirk you to be
a room temperature before you cook it so
you want to take it out in the morning
to have turkey start settling down to
room temperature so when you cook it it
won't be able to hold and when it's cold
it won't cook evenly because the
center's gonna stay cold and the
outsides like fine yeah yes so here we
have a turkey we've already taken out
out of the brine and it is ready for us
to start up doing stuff to it yeah
pretty much all right so we got garlic
we got sugar garlic garlic powder garlic
powder we got sugar
we got pie spice salt white pepper and
we got ginger powder what I'm making
here now is I'm going to coat the inside
of the cavity of Turkey with this
concoction I'm about to make and we said
agen inspired Turkey because this is
actually a method used by Chinese
barbecue people and the way they make
their ducks the Chinese barbecue ducks
is they put this concoction inside the
cavity that's up and they actually do
all the marrying from the inside of the
bird resin on the outside so I'm taking
that method and applying into a turkey
just to see what it tastes like and I've
never tried it before so I got I got
curious and so that's what we're gonna
do today I'm gonna do it for
tablespoons of poison sauce - for me
it's a wet rub it's not a dry rub it's a
wet rub and goes on the inside of the
bird right on the outside of the bird
here we go all right you got four
tablespoons of hoisin sauce and we're
going to dump the rest of our spices
here who ever want to do it I'm missing
up your knife it's okay don't look it's
gonna look like mush once it's inside
that we can now go ahead and whip that
up with it okay it smells very very
Asian very very strong strongly Asian
for a strong hmm sneeze
okay okay yeah looks great
all right we wanna get your hands dirty
go for it
all right so what we're gonna do hit
guard to make sure our concoction you
slab it in there good like to add a
little food it's like we're putting poop
back into the turkey home innocent
husband I don't know it smells really
strong but I kind of want to lick it
I don't know if you want to lick you're
not going to but I kind of want to
because smells very good with Nick
what's next is we will now stuff our
cavity of Turkey with that now what is
that what we have here is more Bailey so
I make a brine out of bay leaves and so
I have more fresh bay leaves
yeah some apples for some some sugars to
go into the turkey mate sweeten up the
meat onion and your favorite more ginger
oh it's not that I hate ginger is just
sometimes you tend to go a little over
in my view I'm gonna stop it we ready
dump it
we're stuffing it gonna fit all that if
any I'm leaving out the apples why I'd
rather you leave out the onion oh my
goodness we're not going to eat any of
this thing I don't like you deliver one
everything is onion places onion is like
the most prevalent um ticky ticky girl
you should I do know that right now yeah
it's gonna fit for poor turkey
well how cruel is this world or if we
fill them pick everything out and stuff
something else back in there I don't
know give over this idea pilgrims
wait all the babies are out thank you
she trying to stuff it just gotta tie it
up just like that
Oh feel I can healthier I've never done
this either
nice look at that that's a work of art
kind of so we're like a triple teaming
everything so we've had that little
concoction thing that we threw in the
cavity we have all the fresh veggies and
fruits and stuff that were stuffed in
there for extra aroma now we're going to
put a very simple all-purpose seasoning
on the top which is just salt pepper and
garlic we're just going to hit hit them
all side and angles and hit it with some
gonna hit it hit it hit it with some oil
first just to give it some stick let me
rub it in real quick so pilot let me rub
inherently massaging the turkey I know
so what's in here all-purpose seasoning
so it's salt pepper and garlic
all right so there you have it we have
our prep turkey it's got some concoction
on the inside the fresh veggies and the
fruit and then a nice little simple rub
on the outside looks good actually
pretty good to me too it's pretty pretty
I like it so what's next is we're gonna
throw it on the smoker
I know traditionally you know
Thanksgiving turkeys are done in the
oven but I like smoked my birds and I
think it tastes so much better and just
adds that extra layer of flavor that you
know it's just you can't replace that
smoke flavor
all right so we got our turkey here we
got our smokers our smoker set at 250
degrees and we're going to cook it for
roughly three hours hopefully three
hours and we're going to try and get the
internal temp of the chick not the
chicken but the turkey breast at 165
degrees Fahrenheit so that is the
perfect point of cook doneness 12
doneness of a turkey so uh here we go
all right it's been an hour and a half
yet so it's about halfway done
supposedly let's go ahead and check on
it we haven't been peeking at all pretty
good looking really good looks like a
perfect like picture of Turkey it does I
want to do that one all right so we're
gonna base this so this is some garlic
and butter that I whipped up and riggers
we're just gonna base the turkey and
make sure that it stays moist and
delicious for us is we don't want that
turkey breast is going to dry out so
fast so just face it all right on top we
want is coated make this I need yeah I'm
doing it right yeah so we didn't make
sides you want to go to my stove market
and get some mashed potatoes I know is
your weak inside
that good yeah looks good nice and
glossy okay oh smoking with me my eyes
are watery all right cool another hour
and a half and I think we're ready to
eat
yeah some pretty cold do it it's really
really cold go let's go inside it's
ready it is ready so you've spent a
total of three hours smoking it and I
had thermometer in there
I used your birthday present for me and
yes I did and we got it up to 164
degrees and at that last degree I was
like if I pick it off the grill the meat
still hot it's gonna probably still rise
up like couple more degrees so should be
okay once you see five behave it's so
pretty look like a big turkey I'm so
pretty it does it looks like one of
those uh it's very picture that so good
very aromatic bring um transport this
thing onto the cutting our tiny ass
cutting board look at this little bit of
it
my favorite could be should and we need
like a juice capture thing cuz this is
gonna probably be juicy as hell
we're probably gonna have a big mess
here no comment I'm gonna do a little
bit there we go
yeah cuz it's hot oh well the thing
about this is what I use gloves and and
use my hands because one it's hot so you
can't really figure with your hands too
if you use tongs or air for anything
you're gonna just test skin that
beautiful skin right there is going to
be gone and so the most delicate way to
handle the situation without hurting
yourself is with gloves utility gloves
with the plastic yeah yes you're pretty
smart
alright here we go ready Rick beautiful
bird come to us woo [ __ ] wow it looks
like it's some kind of robot Oh turkey
broth all-natural smoked turkey broth so
pretty we go
it is a really pretty turkey to take a
photo for Instagram yeah take a photo
real quick
if the gravity Cara what's next we are
going to carve a turkey plate with you
okay true she get a plate we have the
time are you waiting at the nice fancy
it's a nice fancy place were their site
here we go all right wing good gum look
at all that smoke ring by Jimmy Carter
Keeley we're here we go right ready
so this is the white meat right yeah oh
my favorite juices just dripping off oh
my goodness I get it yeah hurry not
supposed to give that part keep it I get
this juicy piece of meat
look at this juicy piece of meat really
good it doesn't take crazy Asia me how I
thought I would
we're just bias oh this is succulent its
succulent how many other words evening
comes from this procedure I'd be worse
describer ever seen or digging for your
conscience I cannot do it I can't
describe it yeah I'm doing it now sauce
is sucking it yeah seriously you're
looking right now oh oh the apple we're
getting to the middle are you gonna
slice everything else
no that is juicy than that
you can just press into a squeeze juice
out of it
I don't think I've ever had this is the
best trick you've ever made we made it
together we did make it yeah there's one
piece of dark meat man if the white
meats that juicy imagine how do you see
the darkness coming
whoo cheers Cheers
happy Thanksgiving right Happy
Thanksgiving
all right right so you enjoyed this
video make sure to give it a big thumbs
up and share it with your family your
friends and make sure to comment down
below what you're thankful for and also
if you haven't already make sure to
subscribe alright guys see you next time
peace out we go to Boston Market now